[Norvig] I know there can be matters of opinion here,
but from my point of view they're all reasonable.
So they would all work. They'd all be fine.
But for the moment, this one looks just a little bit simpler, so I'm going to go with that
until I have some proof that the simple won't work
and that we'll have to go to something more complicated.
In this approach we named the properties.
We talked about the possibility of whether you have to do that or not.
Here we aren't naming them, and so it will be up to me as the programmer
to manage the groups of properties.
Here's 1 way I could do it.
I could simultaneously assign the 5 properties that are in the same group of color
to the 5 houses.
Of course this would only be 1 of the possible assignments.
After I tried this one, I'd have to try another assignment--
maybe [1, 3, 2, 4, 5]--
and I'd have to go through all the possibilities.
Can you think of a good way to do that?
What statement or other implementation can you come up with
to have the 5 properties go through all the combinations of possible houses?
And if you want, pause the video now and try to think of that on your own.